- Ich hätte gerne diese Datteln.
- Gern!
Das sind 300 Gramm.
Darf es sonst noch etwas sein?
Bananen vielleicht?
Die sind im Angebot.
Ein Kilo Bananen kostet 1,10 Euro.
Oder Äpfel? Ein Kilo für 1,75 Euro.
Sehr gut, sehr günstig.
- Ich hätte gern ein Pfund
Tomaten und drei Gurken.
Wie viel kosten die Gurken?
- Die Gurken kosten heute
nur 90 Cent das Stück.
Oder Sie nehmen fünf Stück für 4 Euro.
- Ich nehme fünf Gurken!
- Sehr gute Wahl! Die sind ganz frisch.
- Was kosten die Tomaten?
- Ein Pfund Tomaten kostet 2 Euro.
Oder drei Pfund für 5 Euro.
- Nein, nein. Ein Pfund!
- So! Nico, ich glaub', wir haben
dann alles, oder?
- Ich muss noch bezahlen!
Wie viel kostet alles zusammen?
- 300 Gramm Datteln, fünf Gurken
und ein Pfund Tomaten, das macht ...
12,40 Euro.
20 Euro. Vielen Dank.
Und 7,60 Euro zurück.
- Danke schön.
- Hier, die beiden Orangen
schenke ich Ihnen.
- Danke!
- Gern.
- Tschüss.